this is Startalk higgs field works
because it has a nonzero energy
everywhere there's a little bit of Higgs
eNOS everywhere in the universe yeah
it'll feel because g it'll be missing
that's how I described right yeah and so
when when the universe was settling down
soon after the Big Bang that Higgs
energy found a nice comfortable place
tacked to be a rock value to take and
you can sort of think of it as it it was
it was falling downhill in energy and it
found a nice dip in the energy that it
could be and came to rest that that
particular energy but over that little
hump there maybe a deeper drop and a
much more preferential comfortable lower
energy for the exec field to take the
vacuum if it could get to that lower
energy point it would go there because
the universe one thing universe does
love to do is be in a low energy state
that's something it will do whenever it
can
but it needs to realize that over that
little hump that low energy state is
there it only takes one little part of
the universe to get the message that it
can have a lower heat okay so I'll
wrestle universe reacting yeah and so
the idea is you have this vacuum decay
that will power the vacuum decay to that
lower energy state and all the physics
goes out the window everything loses
mass or particles can suddenly move at
the speed of light time winks out as we
understand it we all become essentially
photons okay and now you say it
dogs and cats start dating one of those
that certain of that so that is highly
hypothetical hey did you like that cool
video huh well how about a bunch of cool
videos all commercial free plus
exclusive original content that you
can't find anyplace else
all on Startalk all-access calm